然后告诉他，
你说爸爸，
我觉得你这些年对我真的挺好的，
我挺感恩你的，
就不管说妹妹弟弟以后管不管你的话，
我肯定得管你，
因为我这些年受你那么多的关照恩惠，
我也成长的很好。
我有两个问题想问一下，
因为也是原生家庭，
第二个也是结婚的事儿，
先说一下你自己的情况和原生家庭嘛，
我今年是29岁，
在读医学博士，
坐标是东北，
是一线城市，
小学初中那会儿爸妈就离异了，
父亲是属于出有了新的家庭，
新的孩子什么的。
说一下现在家里的资产问题，
因为我是一直跟妈妈生活的，
家里大概有个200多万的房子，
30万的车，
存款大概有几十个，
还有一个店铺有几十万，
还有一个还在贷款的房子，
当时大概是100多万买的，
因为现在房价也降了，
但是一也没卖，
资产大概是这些吧，
我爸是还算比较能赚钱的吧，
他一年因为不跟他一起说，
我也不知道他具体的就一年赚多少钱，
大概有个几十万肯定是有的，
因为他前些年每年的话可能会给个二三十万到我手里吧，
或者是十二十万，
就是看每年不一样，
他是做那种项目的，
明年要毕业就可以工作了，
因为我有一个交往了比较多年六七年的男朋友，
就涉及到了结婚的问题，
这两年吧，
我爸爸就不太愿意给钱了，
我不知道是什么原因啊，
不像前些年那么大方了，
今年谈到结婚。
的事儿的时候，
他就对于钱这个事儿上就没怎么说话，
再一个我那个车是去年买的，
他也没拿，
他的车倒是30万，
他也就拿了10万块钱，
但是我是觉得他手里有钱的，
我从小跟父亲的关系就那样吧，
小的时候还是挺好的，
但是长大了之后，
我觉得可能稍微带那么一点点恨意吧，
就觉得本来如果他跟我妈不离异的话，
我会生活的很好，
这种我想问一下，
就后续的话，
比如说涉及到结婚或者一些大事儿的时候，
我需要怎么跟父亲沟通，
我个人的话肯定是希望能得到更多的资产，
希望他在经济上给一部分帮助吧，
就大概是这样，
姑娘，
我能理解你的这个情绪，
理解你对爸爸的情感的底塞，
但是我们要理性一点，
理性一点，
我问你，
你会无条件的给一个恨你的人钱吗？
会不会你要给他积极的心理反馈，
你要告诉他，
你说爸爸，
我觉得你这些年对我真的挺好的，
我挺感恩你的，
就不管说妹妹弟弟以后管不管你的话，
我肯定得管你，
因为我这些年生你那么多的关照恩惠，
我也成长的很好，
我也有很好的工作，
我现在也有自己赚钱的能力了，
你要让他意识到你不怨恨他，
你还得给他养老，
而且不管弟弟妹妹将来给不给他养老的话，
你肯定得给他养老，
你只能这么搞，
你知道吧啊，
但是同时你除了给积极的反馈的话，
你也要学会。
哭穷，
比如说你跟你男朋友出现什么问题吗？
你找你爸呀，
哭着找他呀，
让他有被需要啊，
我女儿遇到事儿了，
他还得找我呀，
她还依赖我呀，
让他有这种感觉才是明白了。
第一你要告诉他，
你对他是感恩的，
第然脆弱的时候，
穷的时候你得需要他，
知道吧，
因为现在我在上学嘛，
所以在北方这边读博士，
其实收入是很少的，
主要还是靠妈妈这么多年来省吃俭用啊，
加一部分的什么积蓄啊，
跟我上学之类的，
遇到啥困难了，
工作上遇到啥琢磨不明白的事儿了，
你得找你爸去求助啊，
你得听他的意见和建议啊。
明白了这块儿的问题，
我大概了解了。
第二个问题就是我有一个谈了大概六七年的一个男朋友，
因为我明年要毕业就工作了嘛，
我大概就是留校已经联系的差不多了，
未来发展应该还可以的这种，
我男朋友是在我们当地的三甲医院，
也已经工作了，
年薪大概20多吧，
但是她是属于不怎么花钱那种，
就是手里工作两三年大概有个40万的积蓄。
他的原生家庭比较好，
父亲是那个大学教授，
现在还在上班，
是返聘的那种，
妈妈已经退休了，
但是家里条件我觉得在本地应该说算是良好的了。
在前些年的话，
呃，
其实我去年的时候跟您聊了嘛，
可能你当时也没太表示清楚问题吧，
他这个父母去世之前是有点反对我们两个在一起的，
可能也是因为我家庭的原因。
但是其实如果说个人条件的话，
我无论是学历啊，
长相啊这块是比男朋友要强了，
呃，
也是经历过我俩这么多年坚持吧，
我想再等我明天上班左右的时候就结婚，
因为毕竟也30岁了，
也谈了这么多年了，
谈婚论嫁这一块的时候，
他目前父母说的家里能拿出100，
如果是现金拿出一百二三十万可以买房子，
但是他们家里还有一个稍微小一点的房子也可以卖掉，
但是我觉得他表现出来的意思不是那么的想卖掉这个房子，
但是如果说我强烈的要求的话，
这两个房子可以落到一起再买一个房子，
但是呢，
因为就是想看好的房子吧，
房价稍微会高一点，
大概都能达到300，
加贷款装修什么，
大概得到个350万左右，
他们家的钱吧，
可能也不能负担全部的房款，
就会涉及到一部分的贷款，
我这个男朋友他的公积金吧，
其实不是很高，
每个月大概只有3000块钱，
所以他有意想让我等工作的时候跟他一起还贷款，
我如果正常上班的话，
可能公积金能达到六七千左右吧，
这样就可以全额覆盖掉我们的房子的钱。
和我爸的意思就是谈论的时候，
就是说不想让我去跟他掺和这个事儿，
说宁可我们想买一个稍微少一点的房子，
想把这个钱留在我自己的手里，
无论如何这个公积金是在我名下的，
这样也不会对我产生影响，
会有一部分的保障。
所以就。
就是，
那就买小房子吧，
别处一块买房就买小房子呗，
可能父母的想法觉得男方娶媳妇儿嘛，
有个房子是挺正常的事儿，
也没有过多的索取掉什么添加彩礼啊或者是怎么样的，
因为彩礼我家里都会有等额的陪嫁都这种的，
其实只涉及到一个房子的问题，
那就别掺和在一起，
就买小一点呗，
就别掺和了，
别掺和了是吧？
对，
嗯，
那买小房子的话，
就相当于他们家自己承担所有是吧？
对，
也不用要求写我的名字或者什么，
你要求也没有太大的意义，
到时候还得看谁出的钱多，
比如说谈婚论嫁这块，
我还需要怎么跟对方的家里去沟通吗？
或者是怎么样，
我感觉你们都谈的挺好的，
到时候彩礼陪嫁你都提前拿到手呗，
就是让独存起来呗，
后面也我进不出这种是吧，
也是之前看的事没错，
我想问还有什么其他的需要注意的，
那你把我那个书好好看一看啊，
就我最后多说几句，
姑娘说必须要真诚，
如果说你想从你爸爸那里，
你爸条件好，
从你爸爸那里他愿意多给你钱的话，
要真诚，
这个真诚的点在于什么呢？
我觉得你爸真是不错，
虽然说他对不起你妈，
但他没有对不起你，
为什么呢？
他离了婚，
他有了新的小孩儿，
他还照样给你那么多钱，
他真不错。
比起来的话，
跟别的说出轨了，
结婚了，
再生了个儿子的爸爸比的话，
那你遇到这个爸爸算。
是一等货，
咱们心里要有这个基础，
你才有可能到真诚内一步，
才有可能说缓解父女关系，
有可能得到父亲更多的帮助，
是我确实跟自己在这一点很别扭，
因为我小的时候，
其实我很爱他，
我也有一个阶段是非常希望他跟我妈妈能复合，
但是后来她并没有，
她生了一个又一个孩子，
还挺有责任心的，
对你还是挺有责任心的，
但是我就会觉得我妈妈因为他这些年吃了很多的苦，
所以就觉得他对不起我妈妈，
但是我妈对我的付出很多，
所以就单线联系，
这是单线的关系，
就各论各的，
我记的那个夏洛特烦恼说你管我叫爸，
我管你叫哥，
咱俩各论各的，
大概就是这个逻辑，
明白我原俩学习一下，
好，
那就这样非常好，
白，
是不是有这么一个桥段，
就夏洛特烦恼，
他梦里头嘛，
他那个好兄弟跟他妈他俩去搞对象了嘛，
然后他醒过来的时候知道这个事儿，
他妈跟他说，
谁是一个值得托付的男人，
那个兄弟就说，
哎呀，
各伦哥，
你管我叫爸，
我管你叫哥，
各伦各的，
就他跟你妈不对付，
他对不起你妈是一回事儿，
但是他对你那是另一回事儿啊，
记得点赞关注哦。